Hello everyone and welcome back to another
attack on titan video. We saw many titan shifters
throughout the anime but did you ever wonder
how did the first 9 titan shifters look like.
In this video, we will talk about all nine titan
powers and their users.
the first titan power we are going to talk about
is the power of the beast titan. This titan is
usually slightly larger than most titans and its
appearance always resembles a certain animal.
In the anime, we saw Zeke Yeager, who looked
like a monkey. and Tom Ksaver who looked like
sheep. Later we also saw few other beast titans
and each one of them resembled a different animal.
Since Zeke was from the royal family, his
beast titan had several unique abilities that
no other beast titan had. For example, with
his royal blood, he was able to transform some
subjects of Ymir into titans. However, this was
only possible if the person consumed Zeke's spinal
fluid. Now let's get back to the topic of the
video and let's see how did the first beast
titan look like. This is the only picture
we have where the first best titan is shown,
my artist did a very good job drawing him, so
you guys could better see how he looked like.
The first beast titan had more facial
hair and he had a really cool haircut.
judging by its appearance, I think that the
user of this titan was much older than Zeke.
Female titan was one of the nine titans, it
could selectively harden parts of its skin and
attract pure titans with its screams. According
to Annie, Female titan could mimic other titan's
abilities if it consumed the part of them, as a
result, Marley heavily experimented on her.
We never got to see if this
mimic ability actually works,
but I think it would be very cool to see
Annie uses some of the war hammer or colossal
titan's abilities. The female titan was also
known for its high endurance and mobility,
the greatest instance of this being the journey to
the walls, where Annie ran from the coastline of
a paradise island to the distant walls. Female
titan also had the ability to harden its skin,
and most importantly the female titan user could
protect himself by forming a crystal cocoon around
his body. This is how the first-ever female titan
looked like. It had slightly longer hair than
Annie, but other than that, they look very
similar.
The war hammer titan was the last titan we were
introduced to in the show. It could produce and
manipulate structures that were made of hardened
titan flesh. These structures could be weaponized,
for example, forming spikes that were
strong enough to lift a titan.
Much like the female titan, this hardening could
also be used to protect the user inside a titan
crystal. It was also possible for the War hammer
titan to remove its control center from its nape.
This means that the user of the War hammer titan
could hide outside of the battlefield and control
his titan remotely. Even though the war hammer
titan was defeated pretty quickly in the anime,
to a lot of people, this is still
their favorite titan, probably because
of his incredible design and unique set of powers.
The first war hammer titan looked very different
from Lara's version. The first thing we can notice
is that it had long black hair. I Don't know
about you guys but it seems to me that the
user of this titan was actually a male,
which is very interesting since in the
show we only got to see Lara's version.
The next titan is no other than Armored titan.
The defining feature of an armored titan is the
layers of armor protecting this titan's body.
This armor is capable of shielding the titan
from significant amounts of damage, for example
shielding him from direct cannon hits or blades
of the vertical maneuvering equipment. Armored
Titan is also the only titan that can withstand
colossal Titan's explosive transformation.
Although this armor is pretty strong, it is not
capable of protecting its user from anti titan
artillery or thunder spears. This titan also has
some disadvantages, It couldn't run very fast
due to the weight of the armor, In this case,
the user could choose to shed segments of the
armor to achieve more speed and agility.
The first armored titan actually looked very
cool. I really like the design of this titan,
its body is very similar to Reiner's, but
it looks much more buffed and muscular.
The cart titan was one of the nine titans
and it is known for its devastating speed
and endurance. This titan is perfect
for long missions since it doesn't need
to rest. It is capable of maintaining
titan form for long periods of time,
It could also be equipped with body armor or
machine gun platforms if needed. Pieck claims
that the power of the cart titan allowed her to
perform hundreds of consecutive transformations
before she got tired, which is very impressive
since a normal titan shifter could only
transform a few times. Cart titan possesses an
incredible speed similar to the jaw titan's,
Pieck used this speed to retrieve Zeke and
Reiner during the battle of Shiganshina.
One of the downsides of using a cart titan is that
after a long period of time in the titan form,
its user would forget how to walk normally and
would instead have to crawl. For some reason,
the design of the first cart titan looks very
funny to me. It's a little bit different than
Pieck's version, it has smaller
eyes and a different nose.
In this photo, the cart titan is
strongly resembling the mouse.
Attack titan was also one of the nine titans,
it is sad that attack titan always fought
for freedom throughout the generations.
While all of the nine titans could
receive memories of the past inheritors,
the attack titan could also receive
memories of its future inheritors.
In the world of the attack on titan we
saw 3 people that wielded this power,
first one was Eren Kruger, he was Eldian
spy posing as a Marley security officer.
The second attack titan user was Grisha
Yeager, he inherited his power from Kruger,
and his mission was to steal the founding
titan power from the royal family.
and finally, the last attack titan is of
course the main protagonist, Eren Yeager.
He inherited his power from his father Grisha,
and his only goal was achieving freedom.
Now we are getting to the interesting part,
the first attack titan looks breathtaking.
It's looking very different from all
attack titans we saw in the show so far.
Its hair is long and it has some very
scary titan marks across its face.
The colossal titan was the primary antagonist
of the first three seasons of the attack on
titan series. This titan is notable for
its massive size and significant control
over the steam emitted by its titan body.
Although all titans generate enormous
amounts of heat and energy when transforming,
colossal titan takes this to the next level.
during the battle of Shiganshina, when
transforming, Bertholdt released an incredible
amount of energy similar to the small nuclear
device, which destroyed part of the district
and set surrounding area on fire. One
of the colossal titan's unique powers
was that he was capable of emitting great
amounts of steam at will to prevent anybody
from reaching its nape. The first colossal titan
looks a lot scarier than any other colossal titans
in the show. In my opinion, this titan seems like
it was designed for some kind of a horror movie.
Even though the jaw titan is the smallest out of
all nine titans, he is also the fastest and he has
a powerful set of jaws and claws that
are able to tear through almost anything.
Those who held the power of the jaw titan
demonstrated significant amounts of speed
and agility in their titan form. They could
even move fast enough to catch most of the
other titan shifters off guard. The force of
its jaws was shown to be strong enough to chew
through the hardened titan armor, as well as the
titan crystal surrounding the war hammer titan.
Throughout the series, we saw many jaw titans,
and each of them was very unique. The first jaw
titan had an armored mask on his face similar
to Porco's version. But the mask on this titan
actually look a lot scarier
since it's resembling a skull.
The founding titan, also known as the
coordinate, was the first of all titans.
its scream could create and control
other titans and modify the memories
and body compositions of the subjects of Ymir,
but this power had in the past only been available
to the members of the royal family. According to
Marley, the founding titan was the point where the
paths connecting all subjects of Ymir cross.
The first-ever founding titan was Ymir fritz.
She came into contact with the mysterious
spine-like creature which attached to her
back and triggered the first titan transformation.
It is said that nobody can surpass Ymir and that
because Ymir died 13 years after awakening her
powers, no one is allowed to live beyond that,
this phenomenon is also known as the
"Curse Of Ymir".
To all of you who watched this video
through the end, thank you guys so much
you are amazing. I will see you very
soon in one of my next videos, bye.